if you ask my dad and my sister okay if
you ask my denim I did a live Instagram
live with my dad on his birthday and he
finally agreed he never wanted to do
finally he agreed to do alive and we had
fun together it's on one of my youtube
channels but he's finally agreed to do
an interview he's willing to sit down
here it keeps pushing back but I'm
trying to get him to finally agree to do
this my dad would tell you I was
probably the shyest kid in school very
shy I was a shy kid I would always hide
behind my dad's leg I was that kid there
was this people would make fun of me
because I would always go like this this
was a sign when I was shy my head would
go down and I would do one of these
things
everybody knew those you know mannerisms
that Pat had but we went to Germany my
parents got a divorce
that's the best thing that happened to
him here's why in Germany at that
refugee camp I didn't have a father
figure and I was with my sister and my
mom my sisters six years older than me
and at that events in Germany for that
year and a half that I was there I had
no choice my back was against the wall
and you kind of had to realize that
lucky for 10 years you live with a man
in your household that's protected you
he ain't here anymore and you're in a
country where you don't speak the
language you're living at a refugee camp
with people from Yugoslavia at that time
you know Poland Czech all these other
people albanian Afghanistan Pakistan and
you're all together it's pretty ugly
it's not a you know a beautiful
situation I learned very quickly that
you cannot be nice the world isn't
perfect you know I tell my son I said
you know Dylan almost everybody likes
you he says dad you mean some people
don't like me I said of course not
everybody's gonna like you but almost
everybody likes you you so daddy you
don't think everybody likes you I said
Oh buddy I promise you more people like
you than they like me a lot of people
don't like me and that's okay well I
don't want people like you I said we
have to learn that I learned that in
Germany not everybody wants the best for
you and that's okay
you can't be naive in the marketplace so
so that kind of made me a little bit
tough to realize hey be a little bit
careful before you do business with
anybody do you live to be careful
because you get a guy to be too
comfortable your sister
before man comes into your household and
it's your mom and your sister there keep
your eye huh you know them say you don't
need to play video games if a man comes
in your household turn off the video
game go sit right next to your mom and
just watch them sey is here yeah that
lens kind of gave that protection right
[Music]